we're pleased to have from the red-hot
Cleveland Indians Francisco Lindor khont
the program
how are you Francisco I'm doing great
have not spoken to you before or met you
and I really love the way that you play
the game
what what what's going on with the
Indians it seems like you guys have
flipped a switch
can you describe why you guys are
playing so well of late Francisco it's
funny you know at the beginning of the
year everybody start with with that
thought process of like I was gonna do
it the new guys they think I'm I'm not
gonna be able to stay here all year long
then you know you have guys coming up
and down you know do I belong here and
that's how we were playing at the
beginning some of the guys were you know
they didn't believe they didn't they
didn't think they belong right now
everybody knows they they belong we all
believe on each other we back each other
up and we enter in the right we're
having fun and we're playing how we we
were supposed to play the game the game
of baseball
give me a great example of why Tito
Francona is a good manager and that he
did everybody gels together under his
stewardship Francis because he lets you
do you he he's let you play the game and
sometimes he even tells us go do this
and if you mess up don't worry out so I
told the media with me even allies he
protects us he makes it fun to play for
him he he lets us do us and at the other
day you don't want to be playing with
the on the back of your head sometimes
back of his head saying well if I mess
up at night I might get sent down you
know you don't want that you don't need
that because the game of base where you
have a lot of faith that you don't want
to add more pressure to yourself that
you don't need can you give me a give me
an example of how he has let you be you
at any point whenever is when you first
came up or whether it's right now as
you're an established star of the game
how has
- - Francona let you be you I was
talking a little bit and he he I popped
up one time centerfield Maidan move the
runner and for some reason I didn't want
I didn't even made it to first base and
I probably should have filled I didn't
get to move the runner get up and I was
mad that I didn't hit a ground ball and
I'm like I want professional basically I
should be doing this and I come back to
the house he looked at me and you go he
he like count looks at me and says wow
and I was like and I looked at him like
man I'm sorry then he later on he sadly
zombie dies like man I have more
business with you about running the
bases that a house team or you're all
here long I just fake it fake that you
can run the base put one eyes you know
failure don't worry I got you won't
happen again you know it just he he
wasn't yelling at me he wasn't getting
on me he was just telling me like did I
don't talk to the team about running the
bases and I have to do it with you when
you're 21 you know I and you have a
Dodgers open my eyes and say well he's a
good guy is it good money he lets me do
me he he's gonna back me up just he was
telling the media that I was he's a
little tired and and he backed me up and
after that I realized that he's gonna
have my back no matter what
Francisco Lindor here courtesy of tops
and we'll get to the tops X Lindor
selection in a moment here on the Rich
Eisen show and obviously it helps to
have a tight group with you and your
teammates I could not help but notice
during the all-star game you and all the
other Indians there banded together for
the Stand Up to Cancer moment for Carlos
Carrasco I'm wondering how that all came
together Francisco
yeah so before the game we had an idea
Carrasco gonna come on the field and uh
the tall's goes just go stand next to
him and be there and that's a little
reflection of no matter what happens in
life no matter what when our teammates
is gonna go it's going through in life
and their family members we we stand
right next to them we all stand next to
each other we we support each other we
have to hold hands and continue move
forward we hold hands
and this is the this is a serious thing
you know it makes us understand the life
expressions and the you can't take
anything for granted in life but the
other day health is a guest and removing
yourself from the fray here who's the
best shortstop in the game taking you
out of it who do you watch what you see
who do you think is the best at the
position removing yourself I like how
I'm so semen love is he's got really
good hands and really good instincts I
like the excitement of buyers and I'm
Seger I like how they dig a hit they
both can hit man it's fun to watch but I
think the overall over us so stop I
think I think fairy story is fun too
much okay take that what was it like a
front row seat or watching vlad jr. go
yard like that in that RV francis that
was nuts
that was crazy from my couch i'm
wondering what it was like being there
that's the first thing you took a hit of
the scoreboard
well those balls are juiced though at
least we could agree on that right the
home run derby balls are jews do you
know how many guys like how many times I
tried
and I'm nowhere near ionia he's a big
big kid too right I mean yeah yeah you
got quick hands quick hips and man that
was impressive that was a lot cuz I knew
he was gonna hit a lot of home runs
yeah but I've never seen him hit BP or
anything that's the first time I see him
the first thing you took it pick up the
scoreboard my god but you got my
attention
very cool and you were miked for the
game as well you know again we've just
met
did you did you have to you know edit
yourself at all were you afraid of
dropping the wrong four-letter word
Francisco I'm just wondering the game
nah I'm pretty good like when I have to
Mike I know I won't curse there you go
but at times you know it's Angie you say
something you grab the mic and say I
hope you guys had it better okay I like
it so let's talk about your baseball
card pack tops excellent or 50 cards
total and you had to choose not only
designs themes images but the players in
the set how did you how did you choose
the people that you put in the set of
baseball cards for yourself yeah a
couple players from where we go that I
love to watch they're fun to watch
the fans love them and then I went with
the old-timers like Griffey Clemente you
know those are icons and I put a little
bit of passion in them with with the
graphic design on okay it makes kind of
making my own you know like I like to
think I have a little bit of swag
so you Adams different cool prints and
these designs to them it made it fun you
know tops did
a good job of making my ideas come to
reality now did you put vlad jr. in
there after there's a late ads now I'm
Run Derby or you saw that one coming
you said that come and we hit when you
leave 400 in the my legs you gotta at
least hit some good base was in the big
lake says it so you have when you have
the name Guerrero and and you hit 400 in
the my legs you prone to be successful
in the big leagues I pass for sure why'd
you put Jeter in the pack
Francis yeah he he's someone that I try
to like be like somewhat be like him you
know he he did everything the right way
he was very professional when it came to
things on and off the field I don't know
if he ever guy in trouble but at the
other day he seemed like he handled all
the media as though his family and all
the adversity around him extremely well
and besides that the numbers he put up
every year you know but that's something
that anybody can do that's a good player
but handling yourself in daily basis and
and hear nothing but get things around
the lead that's some nothing process
that's something that you have to admire
and you have to take your hat off and
and and to him so I had to put it and
there is someone classy someone that the
league respect and someone I respect a
lot and then you know up you're becoming
a veteran fast five years in the league
who have you met throughout the five
years where you're like that's pretty
cool I'm glad I met that guy playing
against pool halls playing against Big
Papi there's like guy that you know you
you look up to growing up and you see
them like wow this is pretty cool Torii
Hunter it's another one Ichiro Suzuki
it's another one and guys like that
sorry they're fun to play against before
I let you go Francisco Lindor
I want to hit you on a couple of rule
changes or rules that are being tested
in the the the independent leagues and
Atlantic League right now what do you
think of the idea of stealing first that
if a catcher does not feel the ball
cleanly on a pitch you can take off and
try and get to first what do you think
about what if you like that one no you
don't like the I mean you could take
first if you're if you're fast enough
ball gets away you don't like stealing
first you don't like that I mean so
nobody just taken off I kind of okay
what about the idea of a electronic
strike zone where an umpire's behind
home plate with an air pod in his ear
and a computerized voice tells them ball
strike or if no track the umpires got to
make the call himself what do you think
of that idea
there will be an umpire and right now
that's what I like I'm part I like I'm
farting so when you can talk to you are
you just saying that right now Francisco
no no no no no I talked to all the
umpires I yeah they do myself at times
but sometimes most of the time they get
it right but I think if they have a
little bit of help I think it should be
they can make their own decision on
lessons like a I got really bad pitch
that's a ball and they call it strike
and that should be like they couldn't
overturn that you know oh so you take
like a replay like you could actually go
now replay because you slow the game
down a lot but like if it's a princess
first time put three inches off the
plate and and they call it strike they
have some something in the ear says now
that's a ball you know and they can go
back there's a ball they say it's a ball
oh cool you know instead of going to
replay and reviewing and all that stuff
that now we will be pretty much 99% of
the calls you'd be right you know okay
but there's you I don't see the need of
every pitch has to be with a computer
okay I got I got one one other one for
two two rules that I'd like to have
passed and the
Rich Eisen rules Francisco Lindor you
tell me if it up for it that no shift
you as a shortstop would have to have
one foot on on the shortstop side of
second base every single pitch do you
like that idea like that
I like good ok that's a good one
and because whenever there's a pushing
shoving match on the pitching pitcher's
mound maybe with a player who thinks
that he's been thrown at the first
people who should be suspended or the
bullpen people who jogging for no reason
to join the fray what do you think about
that now man you know this is funny now
this is like we grew we grow up on it
you know we like my whole entire life
I've seen my teammates running on the
field you know and if you will is a
fight or an argument and they come on
the bullpen space we gonna we gonna have
a little chat after the game you know
like come on man I need I need you there
just just to say I had my teammates
sometimes Believe It or Not sometimes
arguments like the our fights like that
you know makes a team bond you know just
like next thing you know you the guy
that you don't think is gonna be there
is the first one there so so so it's
just for show that they're coming in for
cuz it just seems to me here's tear
comes 20 more dollars here's 20 more but
you but here's 20 more guys just to make
the situation potentially worse
Francisco how about this how about this
we create like an actual fight area for
the bullpen guys just outside the door
makes no sense they got two guys they
got ten guys that they could fight the
minute they step out of the pen they
should fight there why I got a run to
the man to join it pictures fighting
pictures you see position player
fighting picture saying the bullpen just
there say hey I had you back I ran I ran
300 feet I ran 300 feet for you okay
yeah so leave that how it is but you be
up for the
taking care of the shift hey I've
enjoyed this chat Francisco thanks for
the thanks to the call Congrats on
everything that's started for your
incredible career so far and what the
Indians have done certainly of late and
then on your tops excellent door card or
set that you can get at ops comm slash
cards collectibles slash curated -
that's / tops - x - Lindor right there
on the internet thanks for the call
Francisco thank you you got it Lindor 12
BC as well on both Twitter and Instagram
if you want to follow for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app